in the age of social media people
increasingly get to have a sense of
authorship over how they present
themselves to the world your carefully
curated Instagram feed your Facebook
profile pictures these are ways in which
you essentially get to dictate you get
to construct the way that other people
perceive you and this raises all kinds
of questions about the fluidity of our
identity about how we interface with
other minds with other people and it
raises all kinds of questions about
authenticity authentic exchanges right
Who am i right and so the philosopher by
the last name of Cooley he wrote he was
a sociologist and he wrote about Looking
Glass self theory and basically what he
said is that we come to be through the
interactions that we have with other
people by making models of the other
person's mind in other words he says I
am NOT who I think I am I am not who you
think I am I am Who I think you think I
am in other words we make renderings of
what other people think of us and
actually play the role of becoming we
think they think we are but in the end
we never actually get to know other
people's minds all we get to know is our
modeling of their modeling of us so at
the end of the day we live inside of a
construct of our own making
I guess perhaps what we should do is
come clean about this fact and stop
asking questions about authenticity in
the ways that we present ourselves
artfully on social media and instead
accept the fact that identity is a fluid
act of improvisation and that the self
is not a solid thing and never has been
you know again I am NOT who I think I am
I am NOT who you think you are I am who
I think you think I am wrap your head
around that one
you